what I thought was I would end with a
quote just a quote across the screen
from the book about Madame de morte
which says from then on her soul was
written on her face and Glenn Close said
to us that she could act that we
happened on what I I think I can only
describe as it's the idea of a flash
sideways you would begin a scene with an
image you would take it through as seen
by by one party and then you would
arrive at the first image of the scene
and you would start again I think you
can't just sort of lurch from one scene
to another or wing it you have to have a
pretty iron structure now it doesn't
have to be one of the absolutely does
not have to be one of those structures
where of so-and-so has to happen on page
33 and there's Act one and two and three
I mean in Atonement does act 1 which is
long solid and monumental and act 2 is
in three bits he had said also in the
first meeting to making Senate I like a
script to be 89 pages
I send him a script of 100 pages and
just before shooting he emailed me a
script and it was a script of 89 in the
films that the films that I've worked on
it's generally been the case that has
always been the fence i think i'll be
the composer has written to the two
what's given to you you know i think
sometimes as you know is in the great
kuberan sequences where you clearly cut
to a piece of music it works very well
that way around as well when you write a
film in my experience you can't really
tell Phil about two-thirds of the way
through what it does happen somehow
something you plunged into without what
quite knowing why if it's going to work
and if it does work how it's going to
you